你生在中国，却说一口挪威语。这中间到底发生了什么？
我出生在中国农村，一个小村庄。我妈妈甚至不知道我会是男孩还是女孩，也不知道要怀6个月还是12个月，反正就是很没谱。然后我就这么出生了。
但结果呢，我们还是去了德国。我和我妈去海德堡大学跟我爸汇合，他在那儿读博。
然后我们就跟着他辗转于各个大学，比如他在某大学的天文台工作，奥斯陆大学也是他去研究天体物理的地方之一。
我大部分成长时光都在那儿度过，上公立学校，渐渐变得有点挪威化。那你总共住过几个国家？
我在中国长大，然后去过德国、挪威、加拿大，还拿到了加拿大国籍，这对我们来说真是又激动又温暖。接着，重头戏来了——美国。所以我是来美国上的大学，之后就再没离开过。几年前，在特朗普第一届政府时期入了美国籍，那对我来说意义非凡。
来美国读大学，之后就一直在那儿。几年前，在特朗普第一届政府时期入了美国籍，那对我来说意义非凡。
你从什么时候起就知道想来美国？只是为了上学，还是说你想毕业后留在这里？
我就想生活在这里，做个美国人。这个梦想是我爸传下来的，要不是去了德国，他肯定会想方设法来美国。其实他没能来的唯一原因是那时候美国的名额抢都抢不到。
所以我们家几代人都有个美国梦。现在我所做的，感觉就是几代人努力的结晶。我觉得你在圈子里独树一帜，没人像你这样做生意。世界顶尖科技创始人的公关你一手包办，手头同时有大约10到12个客户。
你真是棋局里独一无二的玩家，没人像你这么做事。你给世界上最顶尖的科技创始人做公关，手头同时有大概10到12个客户。
但你想合作的排队名单上，估计有一千家公司吧。
稍少一点。
好吧，稍少一点。但总之都是精英中的精英。有些客户上过我的节目，我也私下聊过你。这个故事有点不可思议。
我之所以知道，是因为过去一年半我们经常在一起。你能说说吗？你上大学那会儿，想做什么呢？
当时完全没头绪。我们聊过，有些朋友很早就立志了，但我不一样。我想，是因为我现在做的事在我开始之前根本不存在，世上很多事都是如此——有人开始做了，才存在。所以，这里面有教训可学。但我当时被迫做了件事，后来也乐在其中——那就是察言观色，琢磨怎么说话、怎么表现才能被圈子接受。
我做的事直到我开始做才存在，世上有许多事也是如此。所以，这或许是个教训。但我真正被迫去做、后来又乐在其中的，是各种察言观色，然后学着变成、说成让圈子能接受的样子。
简直是超级察言观色，然后学着变成、说成让圈子能接受的样子。作为小孩子到处搬家，总是那个口音怪、穿着怪的外来者，这几乎成了一种求生本能。我待会儿讲个挪威的故事告诉你我是怎么学会的。
这几乎是被迫练出的求生本能。我在挪威会告诉你我是怎么学会的。到了加拿大，我居然是从一本叫《英语》的书学英语的。 那本书真是蓝绿相间，我还能想象出来，封面设计像灰狗巴士的座位，就叫《英语》。我读了它，就像尼奥从矩阵中觉醒，"我懂英语了！"似的。
我能想象出那本书的样子——封面设计像灰狗巴士的座位，就叫《英语》。翻开读了以后，突然就觉得自己像尼奥一样从矩阵中醒来，心想："我懂英语了！"
我以为我懂英语，其实并不懂，因为——
英语里有"书本英语"和"实际应用英语"之分。所以，读大学时，我去了职业中心推荐的公司面试，比如波士顿咨询那种。谢天谢地我没得到那份工作。没得到部分原因是他们问我有没有某方面经验，我说"有，我腰间以下经验可丰富了。"
我没得到那份工作，部分原因是他们问我有没有某方面经验时，我说："有啊，我裤带下面经验可多了。"
below the belt"和"under my belt"这两个说法，有时差别微乎其微，但在那个面试里，简直是天壤之别。"}
所以到现在，我还是觉得自己在学着说英语，学着适应环境，学着去琢磨不同场合下词语和意义的那些细微差别。
等等，你先说说，你现在做的公关工作和你在不同文化之间跳来跳去有什么联系？你说有个故事，当你...
我给你讲个故事。
我在挪威的时候，拼命想融入当地，做个普通的孩子。你知道，奥斯陆的公立学校有个叫‘mutaken’的东西，就是欢迎班，相当于一个过渡...
给不会说挪威语的移民的过渡班。等他们觉得你差不多行了，就把你转到普通班。我当时就在那个班里，大概是十月份，我正努力融入。我们之前聊过万圣节。
万圣节快到了，在美国，你会穿着戏服去学校，还有个小游行，特别棒。挪威人知道这个。所以我就穿着个全身的兔子戏服去学校了，连手套都有。
还有尾巴，什么都有，但其他人都没穿任何戏服。所以我成了新来的，唯一比穿我平常衣服更糟的就是穿全身兔子套装。我坐在那儿，你知道吗，我得这样拿着铅笔...
我整天上课都得这样拿着铅笔。结果发现，挪威根本不流行穿这玩意儿去学校。但我也没法从之前的对话里知道啊，他们都清楚日期，我以为我们达成共识了，老兄。
我是说，今天是10月31日，我们聊过这事。但在学校穿这个压根儿不是那么回事。所以我要说的是，很多东西是心照不宣的，很多背景信息大家默认你应该知道。
如果你以为你知道，但实际不知道，那暴露出来的时候有时候会非常戏剧化。
好，那我们直接切入正题，聊聊你现在的工作，以及为什么你觉得它比以往任何时候都更需要。
如果我走到你面前，完全不认识你，然后说‘嘿，很高兴认识你，我是Lulu’，你会怎么介绍自己？描述你做什么？
我会说，我帮创始人建立一种运动，来推动他们的公司成功。如果你在做一个竞争激烈的领域里的第七个B2B SaaS产品，我不确定这对你最适用，也不一定会给我带来快乐。
但如果你是在做我们聊过的那种事，比如我们之前谈到过的Ramp或General Matter，这些案例比较完美，容易聊，但关键是你需要建立一群人的运动，让他们相信一些反直觉的东西。
因为你在创造新事物，如果它显而易见，那早就有人做了，正因为它没被做，你就要打破所有现有的偏见，把人们聚集到你身边。这些人有很多好选择，但他们得对其它选择说不，来加入你这趟旅程，这也就是建立运动。
那么，解释一下你和Andre开始合作时，当时国家的情况是怎样的。
当时全国的情况是怎样的？
我算是意外地成了某家公关公司的联合创始人，但当时我压根不知道公关是什么，也不知道PR是什么。
好，你得展开说说。如果你不懂公关和PR，怎么会意外成为联合创始人呢？
我研究生学的是外交，其中我专攻国际安全，再里面我研究反叛乱。所以我真的想进政府、做安全方面的工作，但我没法，因为那时候我不是公民，所以很困难。
所以我最终去了华盛顿特区，做了个感觉挺接近的事：政治风险。就是说，比如谷歌要进入埃及，但那里发生了政变，你怎么办？这不是正常的商业情况。
总之，我当时在做政治风险，后来和一个帮助马云运营IPO的人合伙了。他是个土生土长的德克萨斯人，在政府工作过，后来成了阿里巴巴的企业事务负责人。IPO成功之后，他决定自己开公司，并邀请我一起干。
这个人叫Jim Wilkinson，我认为他是我的良师益友，他赌了一把，押在我这个从没干过这行的人身上，对我说‘我觉得你能搞定’。我当时其实不确定，但还是跟他去了。
于是，我就成了公关公司的联合创始人兼COO，然后我还去谷歌搜‘什么是PR？’
什么是传播？这到底是怎么回事？我就是靠不断出丑才学会的。我们开会时——再次感谢吉姆把我扔进这些场合——但我们会和那些大机构的头头们开会
比如 Citadel 和各大重要机构，还有标普全球。我会说一些话，有时候管用，有时候会后有人把我拉到一边说：你知道的，下次或许少用点恐龙战队那种梗。
有一次和盖璞开完会，很明显我根本不懂企业传播是什么。我以为就是搞个促销，像夏季大甩卖那样，结果就靠实操硬学。
你当时的客户，他们想要的是传统公关吧？
对。
这和你现在做的事情完全不一样。
现在确实不是。当我学传统公关时，就是擦上擦下那种感觉，“我在这儿干什么？”而且我没有任何资历，我就是个无名小卒，没人回我邮件。大家都不想跟我打交道。记者们不把我当回事，他们也没错。所以都能理解。但后来我认识了 Matt Steckman，现在是 Andreessen 的总裁，还有 Trey，Andreessen 的董事长。我们当时都在华盛顿。
没人想理我，记者也不把我当回事，我确实没什么值得他们重视的。这些都情有可原。但后来我认识了马特·斯特克曼，他现在是安德森的总裁，还有特雷，安德森的主席。我们当时都在华盛顿。
那时候，特雷把我推荐给了团队来处理他们的公关事务，他们之前已经见了一批人。
事情发生时，他们公司处于什么状态？
那时候公司刚起步，才成立第一年。我们公关公司和他们是同时期创立的，差不多年纪。他们还在定义自己公司到底是什么。他们其实一直处于半隐身状态，有个网站，但网站上提供的信息只能引发各种阴谋论猜测帕尔默到底在搞什么，却没有充分说明。
他们当时正在定义公司是什么。他们一直处于半隐形状态，只有个网站，网站上提供的内容只够让各种阴谋论猜测帕尔默在干嘛，但信息不足。不像今天这样有发布时刻、电影般宣传片，他们就只是存在，有各种传闻和猜测，但没有完全定义。
帕尔默在做什么但信息不够。不像现在这样有发布时刻、电影宣传片，当时公司就是存在，有各种流言蜚语，但没有明确定义。
定义不清，但他们聪明地意识到是该真正定义它的时候了。如果你把他们当时的概念比作反叛乱行动，对吗？
我认为他们很像叛乱分子。他们要去对抗那些巨头。
对，他们团队规模比对手小很多，比如波音或雷神。他们逆着行业潮流而行，尤其是在硅谷，和政府合作是非常不受待见的事。那时候谷歌员工还因为参与五角大楼的 Project Maven 而离职抗议。
与政府合作，那就是谷歌员工因为参与国防部的 Project Maven 而离职抗议的时候，而且他们无法进入主流信息传播网络。
媒体当时特别讨厌帕尔默。那时候在科技圈和主流，他因为支持特朗普而不支持希拉里，在 Facebook 时就成了不受欢迎的人。所以那是他因为政治信仰被 Facebook 赶走之后不久。
在 Facebook 因为政治信仰被开，现在想想真不可思议，但当时大家都觉得他当然该被排斥，这太可耻了。他居然有这种政治信仰。他们处境就是这样。
这就是他们面临的处境。他们明智地决定自己掌控局面，创造自己的故事，用自己的方式传播。所以他们在我身上下了很大的赌注，这真的改变了我的生活，因为帕尔默有时会说是我帮了他们公关，但其实是他帮了我。
这彻底改变了我的人生，因为帕尔默有时很善意地说是我帮了他们的公关，或者其实是他在帮我。我是通过和帕尔默、特雷、布莱恩、马特一起工作才学会公关的。
我有个问题，现在帕尔默是那种直接开打、正面出击的风格，我知道那是你们的主张。他那时候就是这样吗？
他当时就有那种不服输的精神。只不过环境不同，所以效果也不同，他的受众也不同。所以表面上看可能不一样，但那种战斗精神和本能是存在的。
精神和直觉都在，所以我才有幸和这些优秀的人共事，尽管我资历确实不足。他们本可以找到最好的，他们可以雇任何人。
他们本可以找到最顶尖的人才，但他们选择了我。我将永远感激，这就是为什么我一直说非常感激这些人。你不懂，人们不了解，他们让我学会了如何……
要是没干过公关这行，我根本不会有今天。现在恐怕还在某个普通公关公司里，做着那些千篇一律的活计。
这话我信。我确实相信你对他们有影响力，也欣赏他们，但我太了解你了。你的性格根本不可能让你安分守己，去普通公司上班。
你连公司架构都搞得与众不同，这世上都少见。说实话，我压根不信你会信自己刚才那套说辞。
是啊，我还真不知道自己会去做什么。
也许我会绕道走到今天这一步，但……
但这不代表你会找到这条路，可你肯定会找到。你这个人太独特了。
我总会走到别的地方去，具体在哪儿我就说不上来了。
我也不知道。但正是在那里，我从反叛乱中汲取了教训：你得接受自己无法进入主流信息网络，身边也没多少支持者，然后索性不去依靠这些，全靠自己闯。
结果，我们还真就打造出自己的天地。
这不就是初创公司的教科书打法吗？快给我们讲讲。
你这话说得太高明了！接着聊。我很喜欢你那个点子，给讲讲，一个想创业或发起一场运动的人，跟反叛乱分子之间，到底有什么相通之处？
他们之间有什么共性？
当年我学反叛乱时，他们竟让我们假扮恐怖组织，因为要研究对手，最好的方法就是设身处地去理解他们。于是我们真的就搞了几个模拟恐怖组织，还得去构思使命与愿景。
你要写自己的宣言。我们现在都在聊好宣言有多重要，我那时就迷上了这点。说不定现在有点过头了，但这也算我的一份功劳吧。一份好宣言的价值，怎么强调都不为过。
不过话说回来，一份好宣言的价值再怎么强调都不为过。
那你觉得什么才算好宣言？好宣言应该这样看世界：我们要斗争或取代的那些人，他们人数比我们多，钱比我们多，武力比我们强，眼下他们还更有合法性。
但我们可以用更强大的激情去战胜这一切。有句话说得好，虽然是杜撰的：一个人加上真理，便是多数。我觉得这正适用于叛乱运动，一小撮人，只要能为之赴死，拥有那种激情，就能碾压一切。
他们真正愿意为事业献身，这种激情能战胜一切。再多的钱或优势地位，也敌不过一个渴望至极的人。宣言的目的，就是把这份激情变得具体，向人们描绘出世界应有的样子，让他们看见后，愿意抛下工作、家庭、安稳，不顾一切去实现它。
而一份好的宣言，你看过之后就会念念不忘，非去实现不可。宣言就像磁铁。
如果你没有这样一份宣言，就没资格去对别人说：辞掉你那舒服的工作，离开美好的家庭，跟我来冒险，这可能是条死路。
你以为自己是谁？除非你能把愿景说得明明白白，否则你根本没这个资格。
接下来，我要介绍本播客的主要赞助商——Ramp。我最近看了不少SpaceX的报道，它是全球最有价值的企业之一，而它成功的一大主题，就是不断挑战和质疑成本。
Ramp帮助全球众多最具创新力的企业，正是做到了这一点。使用Ramp的公司，一般能削减5%的开支。SpaceX还证明了，对成本控制近乎宗教般的执着，反而能助推营收增长，因为你可以去拓展一些原本无法触及的机会。
Ramp的数据也印证了这点。使用Ramp的公司，一般营收能增长16%。所以，当你使用Ramp时，而你的竞争对手不用，你就有了重大优势，而且会随时间复利增长。
Ramp是唯一能让财务团队更高效、更快乐的平台。众多顶尖……
我认识的创始人和CEO都用RAMP来经营公司。我自己也在用RAMP，你们也应该试试。访问ramp.com，了解他们如何帮你节省时间、省钱并增加收入。网址是ramp.com。你写了一份很棒的宣言。
它叫《直接沟通》。
是的。
好。你能解释一下宣言里的核心思想吗？为什么你认为如今创始人们践行这一点很重要？
我记得当时绞尽脑汁想给宣言起名，想了好几天，最后定下来叫《直接沟通》。
这种事往往是你苦思冥想好几周甚至几个月，最后可能两小时就写出来了。宣言的核心观点是：我们熟知的传统公关已经死了。也许你还能看到它的躯体，但它已经没了脉搏。
这是件好事，因为传统公关意味着你得把自己的信息透过别人的棱镜过滤一遍。你得依赖别人，指望别人有善意、和你方向一致、有办法去忠实地向世界传达你想说的话。
然而这实际上很少发生。如果你做的事没什么争议、大家都明白，那可能相对顺利，因为不会被扭曲太多。但如果你在做的事是反常规的、远离主流、不受欢迎的，那你肯定不希望它被别人的棱镜过滤。
如果你做的事不那么传统、远远超出主流、不受人待见，你肯定不希望它被别人的棱镜过滤。第二，我认为自力更生本身就是一种美德。即便什么都没赌上，我们是独立自主的人，应该掌控自己的命运。
即便无所谓输赢，我们也是独立的个体。我们应该掌控自己的命运，也应该掌控自己的叙事命运，以及那些帮助我们达成命运的故事情节。这就是叙事主权。
你永远不想只是依赖别人。所以宣言就是给创始人们一个许可和鼓励：没人会替你做这件事。这是好事。某种程度上有点吓人，但某种程度上也是解放，因为你就是那个人。
因为你就是那个人。没有别人会替你做这事。你用于产品、代码或招聘的那份认真，也必须用在自己的故事上，而且只有你才能讲述它。
只有你才能说得最好，因为在一开始，尤其没有太多证据可以撑腰。你有的就是你的话，而且你要用个人声誉去兑现它，对吗？就像我们认识的那些最伟大的创始人，他们会去找认识的人说：我知道这听起来很疯狂，但听我说完，我要做这件事，我们要一起做。
对吧？就像那些最伟大的创始人，他们会找到自己信任的人说：“我知道这听起来不靠谱，但你听我说完。我打算这么做，咱们一起干。”对方就会说：“行，戴维·森拉，听起来还行，因为你在做，我信任你。”
这事看起来靠谱，是因为你在做，而且我信你。所以确实没有别的办法绕过这一步。
所以，当我读你的宣言时，我很喜欢关于你的一个点，就是那种非常古老的想法。你把这些理念从历史和过去汲取出来，然后应用到当今的传奇科技创始人身上。
所以当我在你网站上读宣言时，我会觉得：这就像凯撒、像拿破仑、像丘吉尔、像林肯。
你实际上是把那些古老的理念，用在了当今许多传奇科技创始人身上。
是啊，公司取名Rostra，是因为在罗马，Rostra就是那个演讲台，从那里曾改变过历史。有很多次，全城的气氛是A，某个人奋力爬上演讲台，面对人群站定，然后他走下台后，气氛变成了B。
然后他下来，氛围就变了。凯撒遇刺后就是这样。整个城市对刚刚发生的事、谁是好人谁是坏人、谁有合法性，看法完全逆转，就是因为Rostra上说出的话。
因为演讲台上的言语，人们重新获得了合法性。所以我认为，我们早就知道如何与他人建立联系、打动他们、召集他们。其中一些艺术在近代已经失传，因为我们太容易被分散注意力，注意力持续时间也变短了。但这些都是我们很久以前就悟出的道理。
最近我们被各种东西分心，注意力无法集中，所以有些技艺失传了。但这些其实我们很久以前就明白了。
好，让我们回到之前聊的地方。你开始和安德烈合作。在和他共事之后，你有了《直接沟通》这个想法。对不对？
嗯。
好。你和安德鲁、帕尔默一起做的工作，如何影响了后来几年你写下的这份宣言？
这是必要，是发明之母。好。
现在很多公司都把直接面向受众当作默认做法。我认为这要感谢Endril、Palmer、Matt Brian和Trey，因为当年不走直接路线根本行不通。
你总不能打电话给主流记者说：“嘿，那个因支持特朗普被Facebook解雇的家伙搞了个新东西，你们该听听。”这太难了。那时候真正公正的记者少之又少，我记得，但走那条路就是行不通。
我记得那时候公平对待我们的记者屈指可数，但反正传统路线走不通。所以我们不走TechCrunch那条路，也不搞Palmer说的“某某大会上最酷创业公司奖”那套，我们直接去源头。
我们去了匡提科，跟陆战队员讲话。Palmer去了彭德尔顿营。我们还去了国防大学和中央情报局演讲，直接找真人面对面，甚至直接走进他们的办公楼，展示我们的东西。
当面讲给他们听，演示给他们看。招募也如法炮制，而不是让某个敌意的媒体来搅局。
对。你以前说过，比如你上了什么媒体，我就随便举个例子，《纽约时报》，为的是把消息传给你真正想触达的两百个人。你以为会有五十万人看，希望其中就有你想影响的那些人，但不如直接跳过去找他们。
五十万人看故事，但你真正想触达、真正能影响你目标的那两百人可能根本不在意。所以不如直接找到他们。
直接告诉他们。
对。
就像你和我真正在乎的意见其实少得惊人，就那几个人，短信就能联系上。你何必低声下气去求别人帮你传话，让他们戴着世界观滤镜，再经过编辑，再放进他们的刊物，最后才碰碰运气看能不能传到你关心的人那里？
让他们过滤世界观，再经过编辑，再刊发出来，指望这种广撒网能捕到你关心的人。而且别忘了，你可能会失去声音的力度。
顺便说，我们之前聊过强度以及强度战胜其他因素的力量。在层层传递中强度就流失了，因为被稀释了。创始人把话传给公关，公关用他们的话复述或转述，再告诉记者，记者再向编辑推销，编辑改完再发出来，最后接收方还得自己解读。
创始人传给公关，公关试着记住或转述，再传给记者，记者向编辑提案，编辑把关后发出，接收方再去理解。这就是为什么在AI行业里现在这么鲜明。
接收方需要揣摩含义。这就是为什么现在AI领域如此两极分化。有些AI公司根本不需要大众受众，因为他们只在乎招聘几名顶级机器学习工程师，而他们清楚这些人在哪。
他们要去哪里？
《早安美国》？
上《早安美国》？凯莉·瑞帕的节目？
对，你搞什么呢？
奥普拉？干嘛呀？向一大群不知是谁的人广播，而不是上一个观众少得多的播客？Brian Armstrong上了个叫Pot of Jake的播客，主播是个叫Jake的，可能就一百来个听众，结果后来增加到了115个左右。
我不知道他有多少听众，但一百来个，后来多了一点。要触达像Brian这样的人，或者通过几篇Substack、几个X上的人，你知道他们信息渠道，直接去那里就行，逆向推导。
你直接去他们获取信息的地方，逆向工程。这需要……因为我不知道当年具体情况，但碰到过一件疯狂的事：我连续跟Palmer待了整整八个小时，我从没见过他那样的大脑。
他超凡魅力，讲故事一流，而且在我看来，他的大脑永不停歇，总是有新鲜点子，我根本探不到底。
停一下，等等，你是不是到了要打电话叫应急播客救兵来帮忙的地步了？
我给你讲个故事吧。
只好给朋友打电话。所以，不，我们只是碰巧遇到，那情况挺奇怪的。我甚至不能透露任何细节，但就是有其他播客主持人在场，我就想，哥们儿，三个小时后，你得开始问问题了，因为我实在……那真是太有意思了。
你得问问题了，因为我实在受不了了，那太有意思了。这有点像，我觉得是另一种方式的Toby Luke，你猜不到他会对你的话做出什么反应。
这让人着迷，但当时我就想：“天哪，我得退出这个讨论。”不过他也是地球上最有魅力的人之一。那么，这种直接的方式只对这种创始人有效吗？
不是的。嗯，这种方式对那种创始人更有效，但你不一定要有传统的个人魅力。你可以更安静、更内向，你可以有各种各样的性格类型，但你必须对想法有强烈的信念。
对想法的强烈信念。所以想法需要具体化、条理清晰，然后你对它的信念必须坚不可摧。那么，你的工作中有多少是与创始人合作，让他们的思路更清晰？因为有个想法是，史蒂夫·乔布斯常说，想法越简单，传播就越广。
史蒂夫·乔布斯常说，想法越简单，传播越广，
对吧？所以他花了很多时间……实际上有本专门讲这个的书，有两本，一本叫《超级简单》，另一本叫《史蒂夫·乔布斯的演示秘诀》。两本都读了，你就知道，他是个思路非常清晰的人，你看看他描述产品的方式和他在采访中的表现，这背后有你看不到的很多努力，才能把他的思维提炼到那个程度。
他思路那么清晰，你看他描述产品和采访的方式，背后有你看不到的大量努力去提炼思维。那是你工作的很大一部分吗？
那是你与这些创始人合作中很大一部分工作吗？
是的。我给你举个例子，一个我在活动上遇到的创始人。我其实不记得他的公司了，我们不合作，但这反而让他成为了一个好例子。我们聊了大约七分钟，其中六分钟他在说：“好的，我有一个业务，任何人都可以成为自己的云厨房。”你知道，现在有很多人在家能做出美味的食物，也有很多人想尝尝没有在DoorDash上出现的更多菜品，我把他们连接起来，有一个网络……内容很多，我们需要提炼。
六分钟他都在说：“我有个业务，任何人都能成为自己的云厨房。你知道，家里有很多人擅长做菜，也有很多人想换换口味，不想只吃DoorDash上那些东西。我把它们连接起来，有一个网络……”内容很多，我们得提炼。
我听着这个，心想：好，你是在把厨师变成大厨。他说：“就是这样。”然后他就以此继续深入了。
有时候，不过是需要一个人，他不一定比你聪明，也不一定比你对这个话题懂得更多，尤其是面对那些技术天才般的AI创始人时。但有个人坐在你对面，
他能把你那一团乱麻似的想法和思绪，帮你提炼出一个综合的观点。当别人帮你把这个核心说出来，你才恍然大悟，原来这才是你思想的精髓所在。现在，你有了一个简明扼要、可以传播分享的东西。
就这么简单的一个想法，能够传播开来。好，你有了一个可以扩散的简单理念。
要让它传播，你就得开始一场运动。因此，你必须怀有某种热情，或者说是，
这几乎就像是使命驱使。你目前有多少客户了？
十几个吧。
好的。哦，那你们正在扩张啊。既然你有十几个客户，那其中有多少不是使命驱动的呢？
没有。
好的。所以，你需要使命驱动。那还有什么其他特质呢？
不然根本行不通。你自己都不信，凭什么让别人信？
好的，完美。我现在想说的就是，在创始人直接下场前，需要做哪些准备，这才能真正奏效。
他们得先说服自己。你知道，必须像同心圆那样向外扩散，而所有这些圆的中心点，就是你自己——那个至高无上的个体，坚信自己能引领这场运动。如果你自己都没想清楚，
这到底是什么，为什么值得你为之奉献一生，那又怎么会成功呢？要知道，如果拿破仑是你的将军，他自己都不愿为此赴死，凭什么要求你呢？如果他不身先士卒冲向那座桥，那为什么
难道我是那个跑过大桥的傻瓜吗？同样，尤利乌斯·凯撒也是这样，对吧？在对抗维琴盖托里克斯的战斗中，他因为穿着打扮成了最显眼的目标，人们看到他
于是大家又重新振作起来。他在战斗，我们也必须战斗。就像圣女贞德那样，一切皆如此。当你看到领袖，或是某个带头人，正在做着你感到羞愧不去做的事情时，中间的那个人必须是最坚定、最有激情、对理想之地有最清晰愿景的人。
必须最有信念、最有热情，并且对理想之地抱有最清晰的愿景。
你知道吗？听你讲话的时候我忽然想到一个点子。
我觉得这是个绝佳的机会。说说你为什么做这件事。比如说，为什么要创办公司？为什么你像狗一样每周工作七天？我在东海岸晚上11点给你打电话，你都会接，而且你还有一堆孩子，生活混乱不堪。
你有一群孩子，生活简直疯狂。
是啊。
那你是为了什么？你的使命是什么？为什么这么做？
我认为，当我们允许新技术扎根并蓬勃发展时，世界会变得更好。在我看来，开发技术往往不如让人们使用技术来得困难。真的，不是“如果你建好了，他们就会来”那么简单。
顺带一提，这句话出自《梦幻之地》。你知道吗？这就是那句话的出处。我还以为出自《圣经》之类的呢。结果是《梦幻之地》。如果你建好了，他们就会来——他们说的是球场。
球场。所以并非“你建好了，他们就会来”。而是你也许建好了，但没人用，也许它被法规扼杀，也许没人愿意来工作，然后你就会被超越。所以在我看来，
技术从存在到真正产生影响之间，最大且最被低估的障碍，是让人们理解它、欢迎它进入生活，并愿意投身于此。因此，有很多才华横溢的人正在致力于解决这个问题。
在工程和产品构建上。但我认为，在第二部分，也就是人的部分，投入的精力和思考并不相称，这部分是关于说服人们去想要它、使用它并为之努力。
看看今天的人工智能吧，对吧？我们能造出AI。但政府会允许它发布吗？人们会使用它吗？我们能建数据中心，我们知道怎么建。但当出现暂停令，因为人们不想要它时，你该怎么办？
因为人们不想要它，你该怎么办？
这就是个完美的例子。AI现在声誉最差，几乎就是最不受欢迎的东西。你看人们在毕业典礼上谈AI，结果被嘘下台。你会怎么做不同的事？解释一下他们现在的问题，他们在做什么，然后你会怎么用不同方法应对。
你会怎么做不同？解释一下他们现在的问题，他们在做什么，然后你会怎么用不同方法应对。
很多CEO都在说AI会导致大规模失业。大多数人会觉得“别说会导致大规模失业”。但我看法有点不同。如果你相信它会导致大规模失业，而你又处在那个少数的位置上，我认为你确实有责任警告人们，努力让我们做好准备。但真正小却非常重要的一点是，说的时候别显得高兴。别有笑容。
当你说明年失业率会达到50%的时候，别笑。埃里克·施密特在毕业典礼演讲时就是那样。
当你说一年内会有50%失业率时，别笑。埃里克·施密特在毕业典礼上就是这样。
解释一下那件事的背景，免得有人没看过，然后他做了什么，你会怎么做不同，因为我想听听你的回应。
埃里克·施密特做了一次毕业典礼演讲，其中一些内容完全没问题。他说AI会改变世界，问题是你是否会帮助构建它，它会颠覆所有这些工作，改变格局。我忘了他的原话，但大意是：它正在夺走工作，接受吧，要么上车，要么被碾过。有两件事：第一，他故事的中心主角不是人类，也不是他讲话的对象。他不是在说“你们可以改变世界，你们拥有世界上最神奇的技术，想想你们能用它做什么”。相反，他说：“技术，这个主角要来了。不管你喜欢与否，你可能会挡它的路，或者你可以与我一起搭上这班车。”这完全是错误的框架。第二，当他谈到AI可能基本上取代
它会改变格局。我忘了他的原话，但大意是：它正在夺走工作，接受吧，要么上车，要么被碾过。有两件事：第一，他故事的中心主角不是人类，也不是他讲话的对象。他不是在说“你们可以改变世界，你们拥有世界上最神奇的技术，想想你们能用它做什么”。相反，他说：“技术，这个主角要来了。不管你喜欢与否，你可能会挡它的路，或者你可以与我一起搭上这班车。”这完全是错误的框架。第二，当他谈到AI可能基本上取代
也不是他讲话的对象。他不是在说“你们可以改变世界，你们拥有世界上最神奇的技术，想想你们能用它做什么”。相反，他说：“技术，这个主角要来了。不管你喜欢与否，你可能会挡它的路，或者你可以与我一起搭上这班车。”这完全是错误的框架。第二，当他谈到AI可能基本上取代
这个主角要来了。不管你喜欢与否，你可能会挡它的路，或者你可以与我一起搭上这班车。这完全是错误的框架。第二，当他谈到AI可能基本上取代
面对台下那些焦虑的毕业生，有一半的工作都没了，他好像并不在意。他没表现出恐惧、焦虑，也没表现出对此的担忧。他完全无视了由此可能引发的焦虑情绪，语气听起来非常
淡定、无所谓。很多人都在议论，该如何谈论工作被取代这件事。你是悲观主义者？还是过于乐观？抛开这些不谈，人与人交流时，应该体察对方的反应。
如果我告诉你，你可能会失去地位、目标、收入和安全感，而我却一脸轻松，笑着这么说，那咱们之间就没什么信任可言了。
你甚至会觉得我不是同类，但起码不会认为我站在你这边。也不会觉得我说的话你能认同或有共鸣。同理，
就像咱俩意见不合、争论不休，不知道能不能达成一致时，最好的策略就是找一个咱俩都认同的点作为基础。哪怕是一些
无关紧要的小事，比如咱俩都喜欢那杯热巧克力。不过你还没完全理解我，所以得找点别的。
大家不知道她杯子里是热巧克力。每次我看到你，都觉得你作为一个成年人，这么做不太合适。我一个成年人，让我觉得不合适的是，每次和你去餐厅，
关键在于别人没意识到
这作为功能性饮料的潜力
你都是成年人了
每顿晚饭都喝热巧克力不合适吧
这就是为什么我不用喷那个锌喷雾，因为
我的鼻子、我的嗓子，我靠说话
热巧克力帮我更好地发声
来谋生
如果我们还在争论，我想回到共识上，我会说，好吧，现在我们得和解了。看看这地方多漂亮，我很高兴我们能在这里录制。顺便感谢安缦纽约酒店让我们在这儿拍摄。
感谢安缦纽约。
现在我们达成一致了，你就会觉得我以后说的话你大概也会认同，因为你相信咱俩有共同点。所以很多公众看到的AI领域大佬，
公众在初次接触他们时，就会自动认为这人和我没有共同点，他说的其他话我也不必当真。我不能假设自己会以同样的方式评估情况。
Deal是顶级创始人如何把全世界变成自己的人才库的秘诀。 我研究历史上最伟大的创始人的行事方式已有十年。他们都有一个共同点，那就是明白招聘和
雇佣最优秀的人才，是你们最重要的优先事项。A类人才会识别其他A类人才，这就是为什么像Ramp、Shopify、11Labs、Uber和DoorDash这样的顶尖公司都在使用Deal。我认识的许多顶级创始人
在使用Deal的产品后都亲自投资了它。 他们发现，Deal是全球建设招聘基础设施的最佳公司。Deal将帮助您的企业雇佣、支付和
管理全球任何地方的员工。这样你就能留住优秀人才，把剩余时间专注于最擅长的事情，为客户创造价值。11 Labs的创始人曾对Deal能为你的公司带来的价值做了一个精彩的
描述。他说：“我们创建11 Labs是为了打破语言和沟通壁垒。Deal让我们能够雇佣和支持世界各地的卓越人才，加快创新步伐，把更多的
声音、故事和想法带到世界的每个角落。超过4万家企业信赖Deal。今天就访问deal.com/enra，了解他们如何帮助你的企业。即deal.com/enra。我听你说过几次
刚才听你讲，我问你的使命是什么，为什么做这件事，你谈到创造新技术的重要性，我想你和我，你在公关方面做的，和我试图通过播客做的，其实本质上，这个新播客一开始就是我们要给资本主义写一封情书。
他说我们得离开这里。那一个人的一个决定，我甚至不记得我是否认识他，却改变了我的人生轨迹。对我来说奇怪的是，资本主义似乎是人类有史以来最伟大的发明之一，一股巨大的向善力量，是美国成为地球上最强大、最繁荣国家的原因之一，它应该被颂扬。
这是美国成为地球上最强大、最繁荣国家的原因之一，它应该被颂扬。我记得有一次坐在贝索斯对面，杰夫·贝索斯，我和他谈了好几个小时，那真是太棒了。我告诉他，我说，他们在你家门外抗议，在你家门前放断头台，我觉得这太疯狂了。我告诉他，我说，你创造了一个魔法按钮，我按一下，任何东西都能送到我家。以前要两天，现在三个小时就到了。
那真是太棒了。我告诉他，我说，他们在你家门外抗议，在你家门前放断头台，我觉得这太疯狂了。我告诉他，我说，你创造了一个魔法按钮，我按一下，任何东西都能送到我家。以前要两天，现在三个小时就到了。
以前要两天，现在三个小时就到了。
我说，这就是你应得的，你配得上所有财富。他只是笑个不停。
但是
你得给他们一个更好的选择。我觉得在人工智能领域的人，我每天都在用AI，对我来说它就像奇迹。我们用AI做播客，别人用它学习、娱乐，等等这些。
但他们没有呈现一个更好的故事。
他们方式不对。况且，有人描绘了AI未来的美好愿景，但听起来像公关，人们不以为然，觉得太生硬。上一次真正有效的技术乐观主义信息是《杰森一家》。因为他们没有拿技术砸你的脑袋，说技术会让你的生活更美好。节目是关于其他东西的。我不确定，他们围绕家庭动态，家里有机器人在做所有家务，背景里有飞行汽车。那是环境式的，是隐含的，假定一切理所当然。
上一次真正有效的技术乐观主义信息是《杰森一家》。因为他们没有拿技术砸你的脑袋，说技术会让你的生活更美好。节目是关于其他东西的。他们围绕家庭动态。
他们围绕家庭动态，家里有机器人在做所有家务，背景里有飞行汽车。那是环境式的，是隐含的，假定一切理所当然。
而技术悲观主义者，技术是在前景的，是关于技术的。比如《终结者》或《银翼杀手》，那种你不想去的未来。
反乌托邦。
关于技术的反乌托邦故事，技术是人们关注的焦点。但关于技术的乌托邦故事，当你让技术成为焦点时，人们会认为是公关宣传。所以我认为我们想要的是，关于技术的乌托邦故事或乐观故事，让技术退居背景，只是环境式的。
让技术退居背景，只是环境式的。很多人读过科幻小说，而科幻小说通常不是关于技术本身，而是关于故事。比如尼尔·斯蒂芬森的《钻石时代》是关于奈尔和她的家庭，《七夏娃》是关于被送往太空的人们，他们拥有保存人类的技术只是背景，是促成因素。
比如尼尔·斯蒂芬森的《钻石时代》是关于奈尔和她的家庭，《七夏娃》是关于被送往太空的人们，他们拥有保存人类的技术只是背景，是促成因素。
正是这些故事激励人们去创办公司。你我谈过许多创始人，他们就是受科幻启发而创业的。帕尔默显然就是其中之一。
不是因为他们拿一个具体发明砸你的脑袋，而是因为他们展示了更美好的世界和其中的人文故事，技术只是背景。
我觉得如果人们回头研究像大卫·奥格威、克劳德·霍普金斯、阿尔伯特·拉斯克，那些最伟大的文案撰稿人，以及麦迪逊大道广告公司鼎盛时期的创始人，他们会一遍又一遍地说同样的话：
展示利益，不要展示你的产品，展示它带来的改变。我觉得最好的例子之一，如果你听过史蒂夫·乔布斯年轻时的故事，他大概二十多岁，他讲了一个故事，关于地球上最高效的移动方式，而人类在这排名上其实很低。
他很年轻，大概二十多岁，他讲了一个故事，关于地球上最高效的移动方式，而人类在这排名上其实很低。
跟其他动物相比，嗯，如果让人骑上自行车，他就能比那些动物高效得多。
因为我喝巧克力牛奶嘛。但他比那只秃鹫还高效，我记不清他说的那种动物了。但一旦让人骑上自行车，他就变得非常高效，所以我创造的就是给人脑的自行车。
这就是思维的自行车。这样一来，你就会想，哦，我要一台电脑，因为它能提高我的效率。它就像让我从慢腾腾的人类变成世界上最快最高效的动物。
这完美地说明了，我不是在卖给你比特、字节和内存。我说的是你用了我的产品之后会发生什么。所以让我们看几个例子，因为我想到你的一些客户，比如你是Shopify的董事。
我觉得Toby在这方面做得非常完美，他把Shopify描述成想要创造更多企业家。所以我想指出的一点是，谈论产品带来的变化，这恰恰是正确的做法。
这和我们之前讨论的，把技术作为人类故事的背景，而不是直接拿技术砸你，是更有效的。关于“思维的自行车”这个类比，第二个非常有效的地方在于，他只用“自行车”这个词就省了两段解释，因为我们都知道自行车是什么。
他就可以省去两段解释，我们直接明白。所以几周前我和一位创始人聊天，他说我们有一个系统，它能吸收数据，然后找出低效之处并识别出来。我听了之后说，哦，这就是公司界的奥泽匹克。嗯，你知道奥泽匹克是什么的话，这又省了你两段解释，一石二鸟。
既传达了复杂性，又保持了简洁性，两全其美。这样既包含了复杂，又包含了简单，两全其美。
所以再给我一些例子吧，从你的一些客户或公司那里，他们描述使命的方式。他们把公司的存在意义浓缩成一句话。他们的公司为顾客和使用他们产品的人做了什么？
他们的公司为顾客和使用他们产品的人做了什么？
你问到Shopify，Toby很擅长这个，他说Shopify有两个层面。一个是这项奇妙技术本身以及它对世界的意义。在某些方面，它是支撑创业精神的技术。
而创业精神将是人类经济价值的最后堡垒。如果他们拿走一切，我们总还有创业。所以Shopify有点像对失业的一种对冲，因为他们不能夺走我们的主动性和开创事业的能力。
Shopify创造了技术来让创业成为可能。Shopify是创业的基础设施。这是其中一个层面。另一个层面是商家。Toby和Harley在通过Shopify对商家的帮助来讲述Shopify的故事方面做得非常出色。
比如Skims这家成功的公司，它能够IPO，很可能是因为Kim和Yens以及团队不用坐下来想，好吧，我们要开店，但首先得解决单独建网页、支付、设计等等所有这些问题，然后把它们拼凑起来。
有多少人因此被这个看似无法逾越的障碍挡住，无法真正把他们的生意搬到线上？
所以，一个商家的故事，从某个人的梦想开始，可能是一个小镇上即将退休的人，一直想开一家果酱店什么的，或者可能是地球上某个大名人推出Skims，把梦想变成如今蓬勃发展的生意，这才是讲述Shopify的最佳方式，尽管他们并不是故事的主角。
所以我们又看到了一个主题，和之前提到的《杰森一家》一样。
《杰森一家》才是故事的主角，而不是叫“机器人系列”，然后杰森家成为配角。他们才是主角。人类的故事是英雄，而技术是环境背景。
在Skims这个故事里，Kim和Yens以及他们的团队是创业者，他们是英雄。Shopify是环境，因为没有他们，这一切都不可能以现在的形式实现。
但你不会直接拿“这是关于Shopify”来砸别人。
好的。你写了一篇题为《立足2026》的文章，我非常喜欢。你谈到了创始人未来应该采取的策略有什么不同。你能阐述一下你文章的论点或主要观点吗？
这是我今年的主推论调，我一直在唠叨的，就是现在一切都显得很假。一切都是假的。你去看看一些产品发布会，首先，每个发布会都用那种粗制滥造的营销视频，同样的模板。
一开始几次还算原创，现在大家全都这样做，一半的发布会你去看互动量，完全造假。你看到今天的一个，你说它只有约一百个赞，但转发却有四千七，你问为什么要花钱买转发？
就是啊，为什么要买转发呢？
是的。还有几周前的另一个，以及之后一周的又一个。我们之所以知道，是因为你我都有慧眼识破，而且我还知道其中一些公关公司是谁。我收到了那些邮件……
你知道，就是那些推销付费推广的消息。我认得那些发消息的人。过一段时间你就会发现，第一，这个东西的互动量与其实际的有趣程度完全不成比例。
第二，当你看看那些参与互动的人，都是些来自发展中国家的随机账号，没有其他推文，除了推广这类产品。当这种情况发生时，我就认为整个公司都是假的。
当这种情况发生时，我就认为整个公司是假的。我不觉得这是一段假视频或假互动。我心想，这是一家假公司，创始人也是假的。我永远不会买他们的产品，永远不会和他们做生意。
我也不会推荐任何人去他们那里工作。整个东西都是假的。
那你在文章里给的建议是什么？如果你今天要这么做，你会怎么做？
你可以做一些无法伪造的事情。所以，首先，最好发布一些真正代表你所做事情的最佳版本的内容，即使互动量可能更低，但参与的人都是真实的人。
他们在乎。所以，有50个觉得这说到心坎里的人，比获得4700次转发更好，那些转发明显是假的。第二，有些事情是那些假公司无法复制的。
这些事情就是与他人的关系。你应该确保告诉你的朋友、告诉你的联系人，并与你认识并信任已久的人合作。这些是那些假公司无法伪造的。
另一件事是在现实世界中做事情。比如，你可以邀请人们到你家谈论它。假公司做不到。有一种品味、辨识力和美感，是我在这些假东西上看不到的。
我在这些假东西上看不到这种品味、辨识力和美感。它们不是用爱制作的。
是啊。你一直说会回归美感。那是什么意思？
会回归美感。那是什么意思？
人们被允许在乎客观上美的事物。再说一次，我们可能经历了十年，或者说大半个十年，不得不采取这种美学相对主义的观点，认为所有事物在某人眼中都是美的。
在某人眼中，一件显然是垃圾的艺术品和一位大师的作品一样美。或者一个明显不健康不快乐的人，和一个把自己照顾得很好的人一样美。
你是在说把肥胖女性放在杂志封面上？
嗯，是的。比如维多利亚的秘密有一段时间主打肥胖的女性和男性。男性维多利亚的秘密。它变得...这不是维多利亚的秘密。
但确实有一段时间是这样的。为什么我们都假装这是皇帝的新衣，皇帝的新内衣？我们都假装这仍然性感，仍然好看。
总之，经历了那个时期，人们现在被允许说：“这个比那个更美。”一座美丽的建筑比一座丑陋的建筑更美。一个漂亮的网站值得去创建。这就是Joe Jebia和National Design Studio团队在做的事情。
Joe Jebia和National Design Studio团队在做的事情是：我们相信，互联网上更美的体验反映了作为美国公民的尊严。那就是我们想要的。所以我们将投入私营部门最优秀的人才去为你打造这些，因为它有价值。
我们不会假装网站必须是丑陋的。任何事情，无论大小、光鲜还是平凡，比如一个简单的政府网站，都可以变得更美。当它变美时，人们会更加欣赏它，因为我们确实天生就渴望美。
政府网站可以变得更美。当它变美时，人们会更加欣赏它，因为我们天生就渴望美。回到真实与虚假的东西，假东西没有美。它们在某种程度上是孤儿，没人爱它们。
它们在某种程度上是孤儿，没人爱它们。
所以，你认为对美的欣赏是普遍的吗？
是的。
很有意思。我刚读了一本书，是凯利·约翰逊的回忆录，他创立了洛克希德·马丁公司的臭鼬工厂。
他说啊，他工作特别拼命，压力大到不行，最后胃都出了问题，还切掉了一部分胃，真的是难以置信的压力。
他给自己施加了巨大的压力，得想个法子让自己彻底脱离工作，所以他开始到户外去，当了个农场主。他说，他人生中最重要的事情之一，就是喜欢每天傍晚看日落。
就是每天看日落这件事，对他来说特别重要。
他说这世上没什么比日落更美的了。他写下这些字是四十年前，他去世也三十多年了，但这句话至今依然成立，甚至在凯撒大帝时代也成立。
凯撒大帝？请解释一下这其中的联系，因为你总说一切都是虚假的，我同意这一点。
但同时你又谈到品味和美感，请解释这些是怎么联系起来的。我觉得你说的品味，是对美的认知。
那么请解释一下，品味和美感怎么就成了对抗虚假的解药？
首先，关于日落，比日落更美的是和朋友们一起看日落，和好兄弟一起看日落。
对，就像西塞罗说的那样。
他会说类似这样的话：今晚一起看美丽的星星是极大的快乐，但与你一同观赏更美好。西塞罗在公元前50年写了最后一部关于友谊的伟大论著。
从那以后，我们就一直低估了友谊的重要性。所以，在真实且无法伪造的事物清单上，还有友谊。让朋友们陪你一路同行，支持你。
至于为什么品味、美感、辨别力和优雅与虚假对立，那是因为虚假的事物不美。这听起来不一定是事实，你可能觉得理论上有人能造假但造得美。理论上是的，但从未实现过。实际上，我还没见过哪家公司或项目既不真实又美丽的。
理论上可能造出假的但美的东西，但实践中我没见过。我无法解释其机理，但从经验看，假的东西确实不会美。我想那是因为没人投入爱与关怀，因为如果你只是想要参与感，何必费心呢？
另一方面，美的东西无法伪造。美就像记分牌，非常直观。一个人健康、注重自我照料，一眼就能看出来，无法假装。所以我认为美就像是真实的印章。
美的东西无法伪造，美就是真实的标志。
美是真实的印记，无法假装。
商业上的例子是什么？什么算美？比如你的客户，他们努力让产品更美，你能举个例子吗？
我建议你去看看General Matters的网站。我们和一支才华横溢的团队花了很长时间精心打磨这个网站，有些人付出更多。我不是说我在做网站，但我们都倾注了大量心血，反复争论，可能争论得时间太长。你看到它时，它如此简洁。然后看使命宣言，非常简短，但背后耗费了很多人力。
我们投入了无数思考和关怀，反复争论。成品看起来简单，但背后是大量的人力。
动用了很多人，计费工时和累积的智商点数都难以想象，最后得到的东西如此简单、如此优雅，但要是不经历那段历程，你达不到这个效果。
如果某人随便搞个粗糙的网站，随便写些乱七八糟的文字，比如让AI写，我认为效果不会一样。
或者更糟，直接用模板。
你反对模板，我听说过。
我反对模板。
这是最有趣的理念之一，请解释一下。
我不用模板。
好吧。但人们来找你，他们说，‘好吧，我是一家公司。你和其他公司合作过，他们遇到过这种问题。我肯定你有某种处理这个问题模板。’你会说：‘不，我们得从一张白纸开始。’
从一张白纸开始。解释一下你的想法。
有两个原因。首先，是的，我经常被要求拿出模板，但我总是说我没有模板。实际上，我得抵制住诱惑。我得通过‘棉花糖测试’来克制自己想用模板节省时间的冲动。我本可以让自己生活更轻松，晚上多出20分钟看书，只要多用模板就行。但我抵制的原因，第一，没有哪两种情况是完全相同的。如果我们假装它们一样，就会错失那些细节。在对话开始时，我们谈到了背景和脉络，要尊重这些。我认为真正的价值来自于现实中那些只有你能看到和利用的小缝隙。如果你只是用别人的模板去覆盖，你就牺牲了让自己变得更好的机会。而我也在牺牲比我自己六个月前做得更好的机会。为什么我要满足于六个月前我比现在更笨的时候做的那堆平庸玩意儿？我可不会那样做。所以，我不使用模板。第二个原因是，我们讨论过那些本质上很有价值的东西。对我来说，本质上重要的是，每件事都值得原创性，而世界上原创性很稀缺。任何值得做的事都值得原创。如果有个创始人我其实根本不在乎，那按定义他们就不会是我的客户，也许我会扔给他们一个模板。但任何我在乎的人，如果我用捷径来对待他们，贬低了他们的原创性，那就是侮辱他们。而且我也会侮辱自己持续产生新创意的能力。
我本可以用更多模板让生活更轻松，晚上多20分钟看书。而我抵制的原因，第一，没有两种情况是一样的。如果我们假装它们一样，我们就会错失那种质感。在对话开始时，我们谈过背景和脉络，要尊重那些。我认为那种‘阿尔法’（优势）来自现实中只有你能看到并加以利用的小缝隙。如果你只是用别人的模板去覆盖，你就牺牲了变得更好的机会。而我也在牺牲比六个月前自己作品更好的机会。为什么我要满足于六个月前那个更笨的自己做的那些垃圾事？我不会那么做。所以，我不使用模板。第二个原因是，我们谈过那些本身有价值的东西。对我来说，根本的价值在于，每件事都值得原创，而世界上原创稀缺。任何值得做的事都值得原创。如果有那么一个创始人，我实际上一点也不在乎，那按定义他们就不会和我合作，也许我会给他们一个模板。但是任何我在乎的人，我用走捷径的方式对待他们，就侮辱了他们的原创性。我也侮辱了自己继续产生新想法的能力。
对话开始时，我们谈过背景和脉络，要尊重那些。我认为那种‘阿尔法’（优势）来自现实中只有你能看到并加以利用的小缝隙。如果你只是用别人的模板去覆盖，你就牺牲了变得更好的机会。而我也在牺牲比六个月前自己作品更好的机会。为什么我要满足于六个月前那个更笨的自己做的那些垃圾事？我不会那么做。所以，我不使用模板。第二个原因是，我们谈过那些本身有价值的东西。对我来说，根本的价值在于，每件事都值得原创，而世界上原创稀缺。任何值得做的事都值得原创。如果有那么一个创始人，我实际上一点也不在乎，那按定义他们就不会和我合作，也许我会给他们一个模板。但是任何我在乎的人，我用走捷径的方式对待他们，就侮辱了他们的原创性。我也侮辱了自己继续产生新想法的能力。
如果你只是用别人的模板去覆盖，你就牺牲了变得更好的机会。而我也在牺牲比六个月前自己作品更好的机会。为什么我要满足于六个月前那个更笨的自己做的那些垃圾事？我不会那么做。所以，我不使用模板。第二个原因是，我们谈过那些本身有价值的东西。对我来说，根本的价值在于，每件事都值得原创，而世界上原创稀缺。任何值得做的事都值得原创。如果有那么一个创始人，我实际上一点也不在乎，那按定义他们就不会和我合作，也许我会给他们一个模板。但是任何我在乎的人，我用走捷径的方式对待他们，就侮辱了他们的原创性。我也侮辱了自己继续产生新想法的能力。
为什么我要满足于六个月前那个更笨的自己做的那些垃圾事？我不会那么做。所以，我不使用模板。第二个原因是，我们谈过那些本身有价值的东西。对我来说，根本的价值在于，每件事都值得原创，而世界上原创稀缺。任何值得做的事都值得原创。如果有那么一个创始人，我实际上一点也不在乎，那按定义他们就不会和我合作，也许我会给他们一个模板。但是任何我在乎的人，我用走捷径的方式对待他们，就侮辱了他们的原创性。我也侮辱了自己继续产生新想法的能力。
原创性，而且世界上原创稀缺。任何值得做的事都值得原创。如果有那么一个创始人，我实际上一点也不在乎，那按定义他们就不会和我合作，也许我会给他们一个模板。但是任何我在乎的人，我用走捷径的方式对待他们，就侮辱了他们的原创性。我也侮辱了自己继续产生新想法的能力。
也许我会扔给他们一个模板。但是任何我在乎的人，我用走捷径的方式对待他们，就侮辱了他们的原创性。我也侮辱了自己继续产生新想法的能力。
我在读《从0到1》时发现了我一直最喜欢的一句话。那句话是：‘我注意到的唯一最强模式是，成功人士从第一性原理而非公式来思考商业，从而在意外之处发现价值。’这正是AppLovin在广告平台所做的。AppLovin将你与移动游戏中超过十亿潜在新客户连接起来。AppLovin让你获得完全专注的注意力。AppLovin广告是全屏视频广告，平均观看35秒。这种留存率远超其他广告平台。而且你可以在几分钟内就在AppLovin上发布。你设定目标，AppLovin就能实现。无需复杂设置，也无需专业知识，AppLovin能快速扩展。他们可以把你的广告展示给超过十亿潜在客户。其他企业已经看到了立竿见影的效果，花费扩展到每天数十万美元，收入增加数百万。所以，趁你的竞争对手还没在AppLovin上，赶紧开始吧。你可以访问applovin.com开始。那就是applovin.com。
从第一性原理而非公式来思考商业。这正是AppLovin在广告平台所做的。AppLovin将你与移动游戏中超过十亿潜在新客户连接起来。AppLovin让你获得完全专注的注意力。AppLovin广告是全屏视频广告，平均观看35秒。这种留存率远超其他广告平台。而且你可以在几分钟内就在AppLovin上发布。你设定目标，AppLovin就能实现。无需复杂设置，也无需专业知识，AppLovin能快速扩展。他们可以把你的广告展示给超过十亿潜在客户。其他企业已经看到了立竿见影的效果，花费扩展到每天数十万美元，收入增加数百万。所以，趁你的竞争对手还没在AppLovin上，赶紧开始吧。你可以访问applovin.com开始。那就是applovin.com。
AppLovin让你获得完全专注的注意力。AppLovin广告是全屏视频广告，平均观看35秒。这种留存率远超其他广告平台。而且你可以在几分钟内就在AppLovin上发布。你设定目标，AppLovin就能实现。无需复杂设置，也无需专业知识，AppLovin能快速扩展。他们可以把你的广告展示给超过十亿潜在客户。其他企业已经看到了立竿见影的效果，花费扩展到每天数十万美元，收入增加数百万。所以，趁你的竞争对手还没在AppLovin上，赶紧开始吧。你可以访问applovin.com开始。那就是applovin.com。
你设定目标，AppLovin就能实现。无需复杂设置，也无需专业知识，AppLovin能快速扩展。他们可以把你的广告展示给超过十亿潜在客户。其他企业已经看到了立竿见影的效果，花费扩展到每天数十万美元，收入增加数百万。所以，趁你的竞争对手还没在AppLovin上，赶紧开始吧。你可以访问applovin.com开始。那就是applovin.com。
其他企业已经看到了立竿见影的效果，花费扩展到每天数十万美元，收入增加数百万。所以，趁你的竞争对手还没在AppLovin上，赶紧开始吧。你可以访问applovin.com开始。那就是applovin.com。
那就是applovin.com。
不知道你还记不记得，刚才听你说话，其实沟通中也有模板，就像自动补全一样，因为我们会重复说同样的话。所以，你和我曾在那个活动上，Cognition是你们客户，我和其中两位创始人朋友。他们让我来，纯粹巧合，就在我们今天的这家酒店。
反复说同样的话。所以，你和我曾在那个活动上，Cognition是你们客户，我和其中两位创始人朋友。他们让我来，纯粹巧合，就在我们今天的这家酒店。
是我发那封邮件的那件事吗？
我正要说到那儿。没错，你还记得。
他们说，‘嘿，你能来参加这个活动，帮我们采访两位创始人吗？’我说，‘好啊，我挺喜欢你们的，没问题。’我一般不查邮件，都推给短信。我的邮件我基本不看。我碰巧看到一条弹出来写着Lulu，我就想‘哦，我看看Lulu的邮件。’其他我就不看了。那封邮件来回了很多次，我错过了那段对话。我猜另一个创始人的常驻公关发来了一堆问题，就是那种‘这些是问题，我们希望David问创始人的。’首先，如果你觉得能控制我嘴里说出什么，那你就疯了。然后你插进来说，‘这些问题太烂了，David不会问这些问题的，这些不够好。’但后来你读了那些问题，就是那种你见过的最平淡乏味老套的问题。我就想，为什么我们会喜欢像Palmer Lucky这样的人？我们让Mark Andre来上播客，我觉得有两个原因。
我基本不看。我碰巧看到一条弹出来写着Lulu，我就想‘哦，我看看Lulu的邮件。’其他我就不看了。那封邮件来回了很多次，我错过了那段对话。我猜另一个创始人的常驻公关发来了一堆问题，就是那种‘这些是问题，我们希望David问创始人的。’首先，如果你觉得能控制我嘴里说出什么，那你就疯了。然后你插进来说，‘这些问题太烂了，David不会问这些问题的，这些不够好。’但后来你读了那些问题，就是那种你见过的最平淡乏味老套的问题。我就想，为什么我们会喜欢像Palmer Lucky这样的人？我们让Mark Andre来上播客，我觉得有两个原因。
我错过了那段对话。我猜另一个创始人的常驻公关发来了一堆问题，就是那种‘这些是问题，我们希望David问创始人的。’首先，如果你觉得能控制我嘴里说出什么，那你就疯了。然后你插进来说，‘这些问题太烂了，David不会问这些问题的，这些不够好。’但后来你读了那些问题，就是那种你见过的最平淡乏味老套的问题。我就想，为什么我们会喜欢像Palmer Lucky这样的人？我们让Mark Andre来上播客，我觉得有两个原因。
疯了，如果你觉得能控制我嘴里说出什么，那你就疯了。然后你插进来说，‘这些问题太烂了，David不会问这些问题的，这些不够好。’但后来我意识到，你读了那些问题，就是那种你见过的最平淡乏味老套的问题。我就想，为什么我们会喜欢像Palmer Lucky这样的人？我们让Mark Andre来上播客，我觉得有两个原因。
然后你读了那些问题，就是那种你见过的最平淡乏味老套的问题。我就想，为什么我们会喜欢像Palmer Lucky这样的人？我们让Mark Andre来上播客，我觉得有两个原因。
至少从商业角度来说，最棒的播客嘉宾，就是像我跟马克说的，你和保罗很幸运，因为听他们讲话特别迷人，
特别有意思。这其中的一部分原因是，他们不像，不管是伊隆还是别的优秀沟通者，都不可能用模板式的方式讲话。
他们真的独一无二，而且很擅长发挥自己的独特之处。
》使用模板，其实是在放弃让自己变得更好的可能。关于AI写作，我有时会说，AI是个好工具，我经常用。但是，如果你依赖AI替你写作，
替你产生想法，那你就把自己拉到了海平面，或者说，把自己拉到了和任何愿意花一分钱获取同样输出的普通人一样的水平，
从同一个共享大脑里得到相似的结果。所以，如果你远低于平均水平，那你应该这么做，因为平均水平也比你强。但如果你相信自己能比平均好一点点，这么做就是在坑自己。
实际上，爱默生称这为一种自杀，因为模仿别人，也就是模板的本质，是在扼杀自己的想法。我们是什么呢？如果我们不是信念、想法、感受的独特组合，我们又是什么呢？
如果你真的剖析我们的灵魂，它就是这样。我相信生命也有更特殊的光芒。但是，如果你把这种独特抹去，你就是在扼杀自己神圣的一部分。
所以我能理解他为什么说模仿是自杀。使用模板，就是剥夺了自己超越旧事物的可能，这真是一种遗憾。
》好。所以，你是创始人CEO沟通领域的全球顶尖专家，对吧？你也为这些公司做危机沟通。我需要确保我理解你的想法，不仅基于你过去的工作和我认识的客户，也基于你写的那篇文章。
，还有你写的这篇文章。那篇文章的正确读法是不是：一切都是假的，你需要发挥自己更独特的部分？
》你对待客户或委托人的方式是这样吗？
》是的，我在做只有我能做的事情。有很多人比我聪明、更老练、人脉更广、经验更丰富，但有些事情组合在一起，我觉得自己特别适合去做。
我必须尽可能多地做这些事，而且必须是我来做。有无数方法可以从别人那里得到别的东西，但如果你想围绕一项具有文明重要性的技术建立一场运动，这就是我来这里要做的事，是我活着的意义。
。这有点像你的使命，你有一件专注的事。我不是在和其他做别的事情的人竞争，就是这件特定的事。我们讨论的那些创始人，他们生来就是要做一件需要做的事情。他们就是天命之人。
你为什么要把自己放在和可以被伪造的东西同一水平？现在，我们被各种假货淹没，脱颖而出变得尤为重要，这样才能吸引到你的人。你必须奋力穿过喧嚣和噪音，才能获得他们的注意。这也是其中一部分。
。
》你知道达纳·怀特是谁吗？
》嗯，知道。
》我见过你的，呃……
》对，我觉得他是这方面的完美例子。我经常跟很多创始人说，你们应该去看他的新闻发布会。我不在乎你是不是喜欢格斗，没关系，就看他赛后开的发布会。
那就是沟通的方式。你刚才说的时候，我想到两点。第一，他有一个理念，最重要的事情是，你必须知道自己是谁。这是第一步。他说，在搞清楚自己到底是谁之前，其他什么都不用做。
，第二，搞清楚你这一生真正想做什么。他说，一旦你做了这两个决定，他就有那种简单的天才。就好像你每天醒来就去干。
你已经知道自己是谁，想做什么，所以就每天去做，永不停歇。
》我认为这两件事，确切地知道自己是谁、想做什么，然后找到那个只有你能做的机会，嗯。
那是最重要的一点。如果你想在这个世界上做出伟大而与众不同的事情，你必须先做到这些。
是的。有时候你看到成功的连续创业者，就像是在做同一家公司。比如William Hockey做了Plaid，现在又做Column，感觉像是他人生中一个大使命的自然延伸。我觉得
可能有多家公司，但只围绕一个核心使命。我总是问这些创始人，你最后一家公司是什么？
因为你看很多例子，你得经历那些过程，但总有一家公司是你不会卖的，那是你最后要做的事，我觉得
那时你就真正找到了自己的使命。你说的关于Dana White的事让我想到一点，我确实用Dana White，感谢Dana，作为我们之前讨论的一个例子。不是直接用明显的公关宣传来砸向人们，那样人们会直接忽略。你要先讲人的故事，而你想推销的东西则作为背景衬托。所以，我们或许可以称之为“杰特森法则”。
直接用公开的公关信息来轰炸人们，那会被他们忽略。你要提供人文故事，然后你想推销的内容放在背景中。所以，也许我们可以称之为“杰特森法则”。
嗯哼。
他在综合格斗上就是这么做的。那是真人秀，在综合格斗成为主流之前。人类对其他人的生活及奋斗感兴趣，这本来就是主流，从来如此。真人秀让我们能追踪那些训练备战的选手的人生旅程，综合格斗作为背景存在。如果你看了一季这个节目，你就了解了综合格斗。就像人们看一级方程式赛车的节目，他们看久了就了解了赛车。
就是选手为比赛训练的人生历程。综合格斗就潜移默化成了背景。如果你看了一季这个节目，就了解了综合格斗。就像那些看F1赛车的人，他们看久了就了解了赛车秀。
Netflix上的节目。对，随便叫什么，极速求生之类的。
我我看过，但我记不清名字了。
那让我迷上了F1。是的，我以前对F1不感兴趣，直到看了那节目。就像我从《火线》里学来贩毒知识一样，那些只是背景。
我开玩笑的。我不是毒贩。
很多这样的例子，你因为对其他感兴趣的东西的关注，而真正对某事物产生兴趣并吸收它。
Dana的经历很有趣。我们之前私下聊过，我想是在录制之后，我们共进午餐时谈到，从历史中学习是一种杠杆，时间才是唯一可以信赖的过滤器。如果你想了解说服或发起运动，就去读西塞罗。这些思想，所有东西都已经解决了，你只需要去找到它们。Dana告诉我一件事很有趣。
唯一能信任的过滤器。如果你想知道说服或发起运动的方法，就去读西塞罗。这些思想，一切都有了解决方案。你只需去寻找。Dana告诉我的一件事很有趣。
人们都告诉他，这行不通，没人会看这些格斗。但他认为这会火遍全球，因为在人类历史中，
我喜欢看人打架。
追溯到几千年前，如果有两个人，通常两个男人，他们就要用格斗解决问题。他这项运动的伟大之处，他意识到可以从第一天全球化，是因为语言不通没关系。比如我是美国人看得懂，你是巴西人看得懂，中国观众也看得懂。我们看的是同一个东西，都能明白里面发生了什么。
语言不通也没关系。我以美国人身份看，你以巴西人身份看，中国人也可以看。我们看相同的东西，仍然理解发生的事。
这样当然能行，他坚信不疑。
是的。我第一家公司，那家我在做公司团建时自学沟通的，我们实际上去了UFC拳手那里训练。我们和Uriah Faber的团队一起训练，他是名人堂成员，开创了雏量级。他和他的团队花了一整天带我们训练，不仅有体能训练，还谈了他们的心态。其中让我印象深刻的是，没有人欠你什么。有些拳手背着包从巴西来到的健身房，因为这是他们唯一想做的事，或者唯一会做的事。他们就会去做，不需要周围有很多基础设施。他们不需要外界的认可告诉自己准备好了。他们就是直接去做。
他开创了最轻量级。他和团队陪我们训练了一整天，不仅体能上，也谈论了他们的心态。最让我印象深刻的一句话是：没有人欠你任何东西。有些家伙背着包从巴西来，那是他们唯一想做的事，或者唯一知道怎么做的。他们就要成为这样的拳手，不需要在周围搭建很多设施，不需要有人告诉他们准备好了，他们就是要去做。
来自巴西，背着包突然出现在他们的健身房。因为这是他们唯一想做的事，或者唯一会做的事。他们就会去做，不需要周围有很多基础设施，不需要有人告诉他们已经准备好了。他们就是要去直接做。
需要什么来告诉他们准备好了。他们会直接去做。另外，他们谈论的另一件事是，有时候你的重大机遇是在临时通知时被叫去参加比赛，在最后一刻。
临时通知，因为你不是那个关键人物，但你希望有一天是。如果那个人受伤或退出，这种事有时会发生，你可能会在短时间内接到电话，那就是你的时刻。
你必须为那个时刻做好准备。所以他们的口号是：不要准备，保持准备。你的大战随时可能发生，我觉得这是一个很好的指导原则。好，我进行这些对话是出于私心，
因为我能坐在世界级专家对面，向他们请教问题，寻找可以应用到我的业务中的想法，而听众们 hopefully 也可以这样做。所以通常人们都在建立伟大的...
创始人往往靠几个核心想法来建立事业。不是二十个，而是五个、四个或三个。所以当我想到你，想总结一下你的核心想法时，你告诉我有没有遗漏或错误的。第一，
发挥你的独特之处。
嗯。
第二，直接面向受众，这些不分先后。第三，你必须简化你的信息，以便传播，对吧？第四，你必须有一个使命。
我漏掉了什么？
相信自己。这听起来像自助鸡汤，但这就是你需要的信息，相信你自己，而不是其他一百个人、一千个人、百万人。你需要有...
对你的想法有疯狂的自信心，以至于愿意信任一个人胜过所有人。这很难做到，对吧？如果你面对任何情况，有一个人说可以，而一百万人说...
“这做不到”，你可能会想站在百万人那边，但正如我们所说，一个人加上真相就是多数。你必须相信你就是那个人，你所看到的就是真相，而且你必须...
追求它。然后你必须坚持下去，因为如果你改变了，就无法积累复利。复利的作用方式是你有一个固定的原则，然后它可以复利。如果你改变原则，你就...
重新开始计算时间，重新开始复利，那就不是复利了。复利与你改变正在复利的东西是不兼容的。所以，我想说这是第五项。这是，嗯...
第五点。还有一点，我会告诉你我的收获，但我会先给你演示一下。我会告诉你一系列事件，然后你会做出反应。有一个男人和一个女人，年纪较大，是来自欧洲的移民。嗯，他们住在美国。嗯，我忘了在哪里，但他们不太有钱。他们的儿子在精神病院里，嗯，今天是他的生日。他被送到这个精神病院是因为他...自杀倾向。
他们年纪较大，是来自欧洲的移民。嗯，他们住在美国。嗯，我忘了在哪里，但他们不太有钱。他们的儿子在精神病院里，嗯，今天是他的生日。他被送到这个精神病院是因为他...有自杀倾向。
他患有这种精神疾病，是一种精神分裂症或类似的症状。它叫做“被参照妄想症”。所以他超级偏执。这意味着他认为所有发生的事情都和他有关。他...
看到到处都是阴谋，所以他因此备受折磨。今天是他的生日，所以他们去给他买礼物，试着想给他买什么。于是他们拿了果冻去看他，但精神病院...
不让他们进去。他们说：“抱歉，他最近又尝试自杀，不想见你们。”所以他们回家，那晚他们回忆起往事，父亲说：“我们必须把他接出来。”所以他们坐在...
餐桌旁，已经很晚了，大约午夜时分，电话响了，他们很惊讶。女人接起电话，是一个小女孩。小女孩说：“查理，我找查理。”女人说：“嗯，没有...”
“抱歉，你打错了吧。”然后她挂断电话，和男人继续交谈，她说：“明天早上我们去接他。”然后电话又响了，故事就结束了。
你希望我对此做什么？
告诉我你对这个故事的反应。
我没有。
你有什么问题？
这故事不完整。比如，那个小女孩是谁？打电话的人又是谁？是同一个小女孩吗？他们的儿子后来怎么了？
不，故事是完整的。这是弗拉基米尔·纳博科夫写的《符号与象征》。我认为这个故事传达的信息是，如果没有一个连贯的故事，我们会拼命去填补它。如果没人给我们故事，我们就会自己编造。
我们没被告知故事，就会自己试图编造。我刚才告诉你的都是事实，每个都能独立存在。打错电话常有的事，我们何必在意？那小女孩谁啊？不过是个打错的电话而已。
嗯，那儿子呢？要么活要么死，但我只是给了一堆信息。你大可以拿着这些信息就走。但我们做不到。我睡前读这个故事，结果一直醒着，琢磨各种可能的解读。
可能意味着什么。而且故事里有更多细节。你可以抠各种细节，比如果冻的颜色、他忘了带钥匙，诸如此类。
这让我想到，我们都有一种“指涉狂想症”。这位年轻男子患的是严重的精神疾病，但我们都有类似版本——我们需要相信周围的事物都在指引着什么。如果没人告诉我们那是什么，我们会试图自己填补，因为我们的大脑渴望故事。
暗示着某种意义。所以，如果你是创始人，给人们一堆信息，人们就会这样处理。我雇了这个人，我们在某地开了办公室，这是些时事，我们融到资了——人们会把这些编制成一个叙事，不管你想不想。所以那不在你控制之内。你能控制的是，是否决定那个故事是什么，替他们填补，给他们满足感和完整感，让他们觉得：“好吧，我明白了，事情是这样发展的，那接下来很可能就是这样。”
我雇了这个人，我们在某地开了办公室，这是些时事，我们融到资了。人们会把这些编制成一个叙事，不管你想不想。所以那不在你控制之内。你能控制的是，是否决定那个故事是什么，替他们填补，给他们满足感和完整感，让他们觉得：“好吧，我明白了，事情是这样发展的，那接下来很可能就是这样。”
决定那个故事是什么，替他们填补，给他们满足感和完整感，让他们觉得：“好吧，我明白了，事情是这样发展的，那接下来很可能就是这样。”如果我以稍微不同的方式讲述这个故事给你，你可能会以为我能用同样的事实但不同的编排，让你觉得那个儿子会没好下场，或者会大团圆结局，或者其他什么。我可以用同样的事实让你相信任何一种。
我早前告诉你的这个故事，如果换个方式讲，你可能会以为我能用同样的事实但不同的编排，让你觉得那个儿子会没好下场，或者会大团圆结局，或者其他什么。我可以用同样的事实让你相信任何一种。
大团圆结局或者别的。我本可以用同样的事实让你相信其中任何一个。而创始人往往没注意到的是：事实之间的空隙，把它们串成故事，那是我们的责任去填补。因为如果你让人们随意填补，他们可能得出任何你无法控制的结论。
故事，那是我们的责任去填补。因为如果你让人们随意填补，他们可能得出任何你无法控制的结论。
我觉得这里结束正好。Lulu，感谢你参加节目。
谢谢。
希望你喜欢这期节目。无论你在哪里收听，请记得订阅并留下评论。还有，一定要听我的另一个播客“Founders”。近十年来，我痴迷地阅读了400多本史上最伟大企业家的传记，寻找可以用于工作的想法。你在本节目听到的多数嘉宾，最初就是通过“Founders”找到我的。
史上最伟大企业家的传记，寻找可以用于工作的想法。你在本节目听到的多数嘉宾，最初就是通过“Founders”找到我的。